I don't agree at all I didn't see the
difference Jeff Garlin's here hi Josh
[Applause]
green room and I saw you on here and how
are you hey Jeff can see I haven't seen
you since you became very very handsome
you used to be very handsome now you're
very very handsome I got the double very
bad so just struck me while you were
talking about not having an act come on
up here that a large part of your non
act is also a large part of my non act
you do a really good Adam West
impression and I am and I throughout my
entire career have also done an Adam
West impression so I thought maybe
tonight we'd have a little rest off
would have a little by the way I haven't
done him for a long time but I'd be
honored yeah sure I know you can do it I
think you should go first okay what yes
commissioner
it's the Joker but evil Clown Prince of
Crime
I actually think yours is better than
mine
but I'm gonna do mine because I'm the
less here we go ready it appears to me
Commissioner Gordon that the Joker
Riddler and the cat a woman have escaped
so help me if they've harmed aunt
Harriet
[Applause]
before of them combining their forces
their minimum objective must be the
entire world I have never been more
attracted to cat woman as I was last
night and then Alfred walked in no she
gives me strange stirrings in my utility
belt I began to bat dance in order to
seduce her and just as I was
accomplishing what I set out to do
Alfred came in with a glass of milk and
Robin slid down my bat Paul you went for
a dick joke yeah I did
[Applause]
[Music]